greetings from podcastville uncle joey's
joint is brought to you by
united harvest you like joey
what the hell is united august united
harvest is the new
virtual farmers market get the best
american ranchers
have to offer without leaving your house
there are a lot of companies that'll
sell you meat in a box no big deal
but it never looks like the pictures and
it tastes like the cardboard they got
sent in
usually the boxes are ripped the ice is
broken
this is done with united harvest is here
to save the day they sent me a box of
meats that blew my mind
pork belly ribs a nice brisket some
chops
sausages and lamb and a rib eye
that my wife cooked up the other day
[__] tremendous okay
the night she went out with florentine's
sister she made a rib eye with a baked
potato
half a baked potato i almost lost my
[__] mind
the meat was tremendous tender
unbelievable
this is straight from the farm the way
it should be
no hormones no gmos
or antibiotics get high quality small
batch meats at a surprisingly great
price
and us and what small farms who do it
old school
the old way you were thinking about what
am i gonna get
my uncle this guy that guy for a gift
this is it united harvest what i want
you to do is this
go to unitedharvest.com grab a pen
united unitedharvest.com and pressing
code
joey to get 20 off the site
with your order of 50 or more
did you hear what i'm trying to say to
you so you go to united harvest you get
off when you order more than 50
that's unitedharvest.com use
promo code joey at checkout
stay out of the [__] grocery store if
you value quality
flavor convenience check out
unitedharvest.com
and be sure to use promo code
joey that rib by is gonna blow
your [__] mind away you're gonna save
off your order when you order more than
fifty dollars
go to unitedharvest.com
press code joey the church is also
brought to you by
cbd lion listen your day
should have cbd involved in it in some
way or another
whether you're an athlete a ballerina or
whatever the [__] you are you got
something
a shoulder pain anxiety
maybe a little insomnia cbd lion is here
to
help you go to cbdlion.com
read up on cbd cbn the values the
benefits
what it could do for you and how it can
help you
with whatever is that's ailing you
insomnia anxiety joint pain
they come they got the kinesiology tape
chocolate bar that comes in dark
chocolate milk chocolate
gummies tinctures the roland
the cream i mean listen
cbd lion is here to work with you
go read the third party lab results go
to cbd lion
preston joey get 20 off delivered right
to your crib
no drama no [__] no nothing now
you need money that you want to buy you
got to go to united harvest
you need some money you want to get some
cbd
you need some money here's uncle joey
from [__] jersey telling you
you want to make a little money grab a
[__] pen
a little basketball oops is back [__]
i don't know if you know that
college basketball is back and the nba
starts
next tuesday i think well next wednesday
the 23rd
today the 23rd is charged with the 22nd
i think there's pre-season tonight
if you want to play some action if you
haven't signed up for draftkings yet
now is the time right now today to
celebrate the return of basketball
on opening night draftking sportsbook is
giving you
a 75 point [__] spread on a theme
of your choice i think even if the jets
get 75 they can't [__] win
but that's completely different i'm
talking about football there
i'm talking about basketball right here
to celebrate the return
with draftkings is going to give you a
plus 75 point spread
on the team of your choice that's right
all you have to do is bet
any of the opening night games and if
your team doesn't lose
by more than 75 points we'll double your
money
there's so many games right now there's
so much action right now
it's [__] pathetic basketball walt
the wall
you got college football on the weekends
and don't forget
tomorrow you got the [__] uh
charges playing the las vegas
whatever the [__] they called the
raiders tremendous game over and under
58 i think what the [__] is it
53 charges are favored by three and a
half
the money's right there for you there's
a parlay right there
but you're sitting here going joey i
need christmas jingle
head on over to doubt the draftkings
sportsbook app and download
the top rated draftking sportsbook hat
use promo code joey
when you sign up and get a 75 point
spread
on opening night for a shot to double
your [__] getus
the code is joey to get a shot at
doubling your money
on opening night of basketball for a
limited time only
at draftkings sportsbook right now
colorado you're invited
tennessee you're invited all you states
that went legal
you're invited get out on the action
drive king sportsbook and here's the
part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania
tennessee [__] colorado deposit bonus
requires a 25 times playthrough
restrictions do apply
see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now before this
do you have a gambling problem
don't [__] around there's help call
1-800 gambler or
if you're in indiana call 1-809 with it
now if you don't have a gambling problem
let's get this [__] party started
coke [__] yachts the whole [__]
thing
draftkings.com right now
let's get this party started use code
joey
and let's make some [__] cash let's
do this [__]
oh sorry about that here's your little
lighter from [__] uh
how do you get those i'll let you know
soon you got to sniff my nutsack to get
those
candles lit let's get this party started
look who it is what's happening check
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here
greetings to uncle joey's joint it's
wednesday
the 16th of the month you got nine good
[__] days before christmas
everybody's happy we're ready we're
about to get about a [__] foot of
snow here
so as you can see i got the [__] lay
on
with the layer on top of that just in
case so there's
no misunderstandings the garage is clean
so both cars could fit and that's it
and that's that i got a funny [__]
joe diaz-ism for you
just to let you know the type of week i
was having so
the surgery got pushed back to january
8th
and right now i'm looking for uh they
sent me some paperwork
to look for rehab services so i gotta go
different people
and you know submit [__] i had to go to
a couple different towns
one being sandville the house of bon
jovi
i love you you know representing jersey
the whole [__] thing
i had to drive through colt's neck
that's where bruce springsteen has lived
did i see him no i didn't see anybody
but [__] deer
but uh i had to go to different places
so monday on the way back this is just a
funny story real quick just to get this
started
just to let you know about the world of
joe diaz
and what i go through when you
[__] aren't around with a
camera
because it's very hard to i wouldn't
want a camera around me anyway
it would be funny i would have the
number one show on tv
but it's just too much you people
wouldn't even believe it you can't write
half this [__]
so i'm a crowd therapy guy i
also do the novathor which is the red
light therapy on the bed
and i feel that ever since i've moved
from california not to
sound like johnny [__] granola
but the crowd therapy was really [__]
working it's the truth i don't want
people to say oh
joey's all [__] west coast and [__]
no
you know i'm just trying to tell you the
truth that when it came to those uh
type of treatments
they're a little bit more open-minded on
the west coast than they are here
even though my doctor gave me the same
alternative
as they have out there the blood stem
stuff i just can't deal with the [__]
needle you know
dean delray said he had a needle in his
[__] neck
and he passed out twice during the
procedure and he kept waking up to a
[__] smoothie
and he would go under again i can't do
that [__] i can't drain for that long
you got my arm for about a minute
whatever blood you gotta take out of me
you got about a [__] minute so ever
since
i [__] got my teeth fixed i can't
bite my nails no more so the habit of
biting my nails
is [__] gone so i got nails now now
for you people who don't know it i got a
lot of problems
with my skin i got itchy skin i got foot
fungus i got the fungi nail
i've had ringworm i've had third degree
[__] sunburn
i get i just got skin issues when i was
a kid i couldn't take a shower at a
public [__] place
because my feet would get fungus right
away but bad
like adult fungus that's why i used to
have to wear flip-flops and
i was that [__] kid in the corner in
karate with socks on
that's me i'm not i'm not ashamed it's
just
the way life is over the years through
the drugs in prison and hanging out with
dirty people
you build the tolerance but i still get
issues from time to time
i get [__] rashes or whatever and now
i got the nails so
my skin issues don't come up till
nighttime
late at night when i'm sleeping is when
i scratch i must get hot
and i must get itchy there's mornings i
wake up and there's blood on the bed and
[__]
oh yeah there's the mornings i wake up
and there's a little like
little patches of blood here and there i
might have scratched my neck or i might
have scratched my back
but basically it's my thighs it's the
back of my thighs that get itchy
my ass cheeks and my ball sack or
whatever that area around there i just
scratch it
and i get heat rashes like every other
man you know i put powder i treat it
but some nights you go to bed you know
whatever maybe i
i listen you should drink
if you're over 50 if you're over 40 you
should drink a tall glass of water
before you go to bed so you don't
dehydrate that's
when you're over 50 you should drink a
glass of water
and take a baby aspirin so you won't
have a heart attack between six in the
morning at 12.
that's the highest possibility of that's
the highest time of the day
for a male over 50 or a female to have a
heart attack
so you should take an aspirin and drink
a glass of water
i drink tea and while at night i drink
up to you know two things of water
that means i [__] don't sleep solid
that means i gotta pee two times
in the middle of a [__] night and it
sucks
it sucks dick for you guys who go for
your young guys you're like what the
[__] that joey talking about
give it time [__] what you start
getting older you got to get up to pee
in the middle all night
to be honest with you guys it's usually
one time a night
if i drink two bottles of water before i
go to bed
sometimes i just drink all night you
just drink water water water
you start after dinner you know when
you're smoking reef you gotta dehydrate
and bam you [__]
you drink the [__] water anyway my
skin must get dry at night
i scratch myself to death long story
short
i'm coming back yesterday from one of
the rehab places
and i heard from the great plan that
there was a place that had cryotherapy
so i said let me stop in there and get a
brochure
and see what type of services they have
they have uh the red light up
place they have massages they have
floating they have it's a great place
himalayan salts i recommend it to
anybody
who has some type of problems that they
want to straighten out
the red light uh steam i was turned on
to it by jimmy florentine
and another guy it's [__] tremendous
you sweat
minimally but it cleans out your lungs
just a bunch of benefits go on himalayan
salt.com
and uh read up on it i i'm they're not a
sponsor anything i'm just telling you
that if you live in jersey i don't know
if they're somewhere else it's a pretty
interesting place to bat everything is
made of salt
so the whole time you're breathing salt
anyway
i go to a yes diane ladies like you know
i want my services because if you like
you could try one of the things today
i've never floated before
now you know rogan talks about floating
a lot of people talk about the benefits
of floating
i had some time to kill
i go let me jump in the [__] thing
and float okay
she tells what i need to do she gives me
a robe a [__] towel
the whole [__] thing
i put the [__] ear muffs in you know
the thing for your neck i get in the
floater
i'm not in that [__] water two
minutes
and that salt is getting into all my
cuts
and everything and i'm [__] stinging
like i'm getting stung by bees
but it wasn't the itch it wasn't the
[__] scratches on my thigh
what the salt really attacked me was i
must have had a hemorrhoid dead i had
been dead like
rich vas said he had a little it felt
like whenever he wiped his ass he had a
raisin
on his ass so he asked the doctor to
look at his ass last time he went for a
colonoscopy
and the doctor told him it was a dead
hemorrhoid that had sucked up now the
whole summer
when i flew and all that [__] i must
have gotten a hemorrhoid from the stress
it was like a little gumball on my ass i
would wipe it
[__] tremendous i would take a [__]
and you could see the dent in the [__]
from the [__] hemorrhoid it was like
when you shoot a gun and it has the
[__]
so if anybody can if you found my [__]
you could go that's joey diaz's because
he got a little notch on the end there
from the [__] hemorrhoid
was bumping into this [__] true story
you can't make this [__] up
i'm sorry it's [__] wednesday we need
to lighten up a little bit all right
the electoral votes in for you [__]
people
so we need to [__] lighten up a
little bit all right so
uh let me tell you something when that
saw water surrounded that [__]
hemorrhoid dog
i felt like jesus wasn't a jesus that
rubs salts on his wounds
i was laying there my [__] hemorrhoid
was on [__] fire
i'm getting dizzy my legs were on fire
the whole [__] thing
let me tell you something it was torture
i did it for as long as i could
and finally i had to get the [__] out of
there and jump in the shower
and wash all my stuff that [__]
hemorrhoid on me
must have hurt for [__] two hours
after that after i left that [__]
place
my [__] was stinging so if you the
moral of the story is
if you got hemorrhoids don't [__]
float in the salt tank all right
that's lesson number one today just to
get it out of the way
lesson number two i want to talk to you
[__] about
is also very important uh
we had a good time this week talking
about first we talked about the [__]
the switch getting turned on and then
number two we switched it up a little
bit
and we talked about you know
waking up like [__]
i don't even know how the [__] we got
involved in it just waking the [__] up
you know like
what happened to me on december 18th
which is going to be
my friday anniversary we talked about
all these things you know
let's talk a little bit about [__]
failure today
you know and why we're so [__] scared
as americans or as human beings why do i
have to say americans
why are we as human beings so scared
of trying new things and being in our
shell
you know again i'm i don't point out
particular [__] emails i point out
different emails that i get from
facebook
twitter you know patreon and i look at
this and i make an evaluation
of what i really want to talk about what
are the needs that you guys needs to get
filled in
just so you don't lose your mind okay a
lot of 20 and 30 year olds
uh especially in their young 30s you're
going through a feeling of anger
confusion and frustration
with the key one being frustration
that key one is frustration you know why
because things ain't moving at the speed
you anticipated them to move
have you ever thought about that we want
what we want and we want it right the
[__] now
you know uh you know heroin is great you
shoot it and within two minutes you're
[__] buzzed you know
you put a [__] pill in your mouth and
within 45 minutes you're high or
whatever long it takes you know
uh you know you smoke pot whatever the
[__] you do drink alcohol
everything was so used to quickness
you know quickness we we want food
delivered
you know it's everything is 40 [__]
minutes well you know what
when it comes to life it doesn't boil
down to 45
minutes i mean we all wish it did we did
was so used to everything being in our
[__] fingertips
you know especially when we're growing
up everything is on our [__]
fingertips
especially now with technology you know
i'm not better than any of you guys i'm
not better than any of you guys at all
the differences the differences are
we were raised at different times we
were raised at different times
when i was raised there was four [__]
channels so if you wanted to watch tv
you had one of those four
[__] channels to look at so think
about it you got four channels
and you got a playground outside okay
everything changed that dynamic changed
over the years we got cable tv you know
it got more comfortable to be in [__]
at home
you know uh parents worry so they tell
their kids
to [__] just stay in whatever so i
came from a different world
than when you came from uh so let's get
that out of the way
i'm not talking about me i'm talking
about what's going on in today's [__]
world
as a 20 to a 30 year old this is what
you're feeling
can you imagine you come out of [__]
college and you [__]
you got this amount of [__] loans and
now you put out
you know your resumes you get a job
you get good pay the whole [__] thing
but now you start all over again that's
a complete different struggle
now you're moving up the corporate
ladder now
this guy's telling you orders this guy's
telling you this then yeah somewhere
along the line you realize this isn't
what you want to do
whatever the [__] it may be whatever the
[__]
it may be the thing that he sure crawled
the most
is the same thing that he did micro the
most between the ages of 30
20 and 30 [__] five that it wasn't
happening fast enough why is it
happening for them
fast enough and it's not happening for
me
as fast as i can well maybe they had
some type of help
maybe they had some type of help from
their father may you never know and i'm
not putting anybody down here
i'm not talking about trust funds or
anything like that i'm just saying help
help is a big one we're all looking for
that one person to help us
an uncle a friend somebody put a stake
in us
you know somebody to [__] lend us
money to get our venture off the [__]
ground
but you know what you know why nobody's
lending you money
because you wouldn't know what to do
with it if somebody
gave you that [__] money so sometimes
be grateful
because you wouldn't know what to do
with it no but
okay joey before he was saying and then
i'm right
yeah you would probably fail and
but would you really know why you failed
at that
age would you just say it just didn't
work
selling orange just doesn't work in
[__] northern new jersey
okay did you sell hard enough did you
really put your effort into this [__]
did you really put everything you had
into this [__] or did it just didn't
[__] work
ah that's a question you gotta ask
yourself so yeah
we want everything quick but we
never [__] realized what we
never [__] realized
is that every [__] day that we get up
and we move towards something you may
not notice it
but let me simplify it as simple as
simple as i can that i learned on my own
you ready for this one
every day you are a work in progress
you dumb [__] and when i say
this to you i'm not calling you a dumb
[__]
i'm saying this this is if this is like
a mirror
i'm calling myself a dumb [__]
because that's what i finally had to
tell myself one day
that's what i had to tell myself one day
when in 1995
after the contest after i had put all
this work in
after everything i asked myself all
right i'm in this [__] jam now for
five years
i'm still making eight thousand dollars
a year
[Laughter]
can you imagine can you imagine being a
parent
guys and your son comes in looking happy
and [__]
and you have another son that's a
[__] doctor and [__]
and you got a son that made 8 400
in 1986 i think i made
8 900 for the year
8 000
that's poverty why the [__]
would somebody even consider doing that
that is less than a thousand dollars a
month
my best bet is to slip and fall and
break my skull
and collect this ability i would get
more money you
[__] [__] but why the [__] would i
continue to do something
after i only made 80
let's just circle it off to a [__]
round number
nine thousand dollars after
five years would you stick it out after
you made nine
thousand dollars after five years how
about you mike
would you thinking about it would you
you think about doing something else as
a profession
or if you love something
if i love it i'd do it and i still get
another job okay
still i did all that stuff i did
comedy in seattle there were things
called corporate events like we did um
me and josh wolf would do every saturday
it was a company
that used you as an extra
so on saturday mornings me and josh
would drive to [__] tacoma washington
to like a [__] d studio
and some guy would do we would do videos
for ups or companies like that that only
people in ups would see
i'm training like and i'm just saying
ups please don't quote me on this
it could have been a t it could have
been one of those companies
i forget it was i just remember one time
we just had to carry boxes
back and forth like with like a yellow
vest on
while the guy the spokesman was talking
about health or
osha standards or whatever you know
at the end of five years in 1996
i was making nine thousand dollars a
year
that is basically embarrassing
but something hit me
something dawned on me that it was a
work
in progress that is [__]
big to come to yourself and say that to
yourself
and guess what guys in 1996
i was in the depths of cocaine i was at
the depths of drugs
i was at the depths of reefer i was in
the depth of anger
over my divorce i was in a depth of
frustration and anger
over the loss of my child and i still
had enough common sense to go
in 1992
i was making 200 a month
off i'm saying that's
2400 a year
24 hundred a year
i made 2 400 a year
in 1992
from comedy why would you stick with it
again in 2019
96 i made 9 000 off comedy
so my income went up 60
let's say i don't know i'm not [__] i
would calculate it here
i'm not [__] confused with a [__]
abacus whatever the [__] i'm supposed to
have
i'm just letting you know this that
these are the true [__] numbers
okay but let me break that down for you
again
i always knew something from the
beginning of this
i always knew again it's karmic
the universe takes care of you every
time you do something
and it's free or they don't pay you the
amount
that you're going to get it's considered
a punch-in
okay you know when you take your time
card and punch it in
and it tells you 9 22 and then you go
back and [__] 11 58 and you go back
at 12
31 then you punch out at five
life has a [__] punch card same thing
you don't believe me don't believe me i
don't give a [__] i'm telling you
life has a punch card and you every day
you punch that card in every day
every day you punch that card in
regardless
of what people tell you you're wasting
your time
it's never going to happen
[Music]
you know there's always people that try
to get you with trick questions
how you're going to do this how you're
going to do that
and you you know you laugh you get a
little discouraged
but in 1996
when i saw i don't even think i filed
taxes i mean why file taxes
nine thousand dollars they don't care
about you and you don't care about them
and they're not going to come looking
for you it's when you owe them 99
000 they're gonna come looking for you
but you made nine thousand dollars
they're just gonna [__]
go who gives a [__] what do we get from
that whatever
we'll get them later on the [__]
rebound and
they do and they will okay
we'll get that back to later on that
that was my figure i'm in 1996
i made 9 000
now let's flash forward
to a year after that 1997
okay i end up moving to la
i think when i moved
let's just say for [__] and giggles
i had maybe 500 and that could be a big
[__] lie
but i know it wasn't more than 500 i
knew that when i left
i borrowed some money from some guy and
told him i'd be back on an hour with an
eight ball or something
that was part of my income and there was
like a hundred hours from a gig i had
done the night before
if it wasn't for the girl i was dating
at the time
she financed the whole trip down i'm not
i'm not ashamed to admit the truth that
that's just the way it was
she wanted to go down i told i didn't
have the money to move
she said we'd figure it out once we got
down there
and i went down there now i went to l.a
[__] blind
like everybody else i went to la
to do a pilot and to pick up a check
that they had given me
and that was it that was the extent of
my l.a
i didn't think i was going to stay in
l.a and live in l.a
or whatever [__] succeed in l.a i'll
tell you the story that i'll end it with
this story
i got that way in january of 97 like
every other [__] schmuck
i didn't know what i was doing i by the
luck of god
i became a regular at the comedy store
in uh
february of 97 i don't know how it was
mitzi sure liked me she didn't like
whatever
uh i took it very seriously
the switch was on i took it as [__]
serious as i could i
knew i was fortunate to be there
considering who the [__] i was what i
had done in my life
and where i had come from my life
and i promised myself i wasn't going to
spin my wheels
that i would do everything as i should
do
luckily in february when i uh when i got
there in january
i became a regular at the store in
february but something else happened in
february
uh an agent from sudden barton bernardi
saw me
they're not together anymore but they
were a great commercial agent
at the time this was
february of 97 i mean quickly
you know they came up to me at the
improv
the guy's name was neil and his
assistant's name was mike
who i'm still dear friends with uh
big time yankee fan so we talk all the
time he's
living in california he's at the bobby
ball
agency uh mike was his assistant
and they asked me if i was interested
in being a commercial actor and i was
like
i i know nothing about this
i know nothing about commercial acting i
know
i know dick about dick you know so i
[__]
uh i did what most people would do
i lied and they asked me if i had ever
done a workshop or anything
and i said yeah i'd done a workshop in
seattle or some [__]
and i lied you know what you usually do
because you figure that you'll catch on
later i mean how
much different is the commercial from
acting i didn't know
but i was about to find out the easy the
hard way
so i uh signed with them the first
audition
they sent me on was church's
[__] chicken
uh i still remember the location on
sunset i'll never forget it
i walked in there and i immediately
shipped my pants
there was uh you know 20 other comics in
there
and 30 of other actors immediately i
thought about my life and i said
there's no chance of me getting in there
i i did what they told me i
i signed the list i waited for somebody
to say
joey diaz come in i went in there
i took the direction i left there
feeling like [__]
you know johnny bananas and
i got dick and then an hour later
i got a call from doug stanhope at the
time and he calls me and tells me that
judy brown drew
aka judy mormel one of the best managers
in the business today
she manages whitney and bert and
sebastian maniscalco i've known her
since colorado in 19
92 91 93 i've known judy marmel
i got a call from doug stanhope that
judy mark judy marmel was looking for me
to read for the jenny mccarthy show
i was going to drive chaz palm and terry
uh in a some type of [__] uh
scene my head almost
blew the [__] up
i'm here a [__] two months and i'm
gonna meet chaz mom and terry
so i'll never forget going into the room
it was
judy and a camera and another person
and me just saying what i thought i was
supposed to say
and just eating a bag of [__] dicks
just like those auditions i talked about
before on the church when you
you walk in they're like thank you for
coming in today
that read was fantastic and i'm sure
when you walk out they look at each
other and go
was he [__] bad we'll never it was
one of those situations i could feel it
when i walked out of there i remember
taking the [__] sheet of paper and
just ranking it up
and throwing it in the garbage and
leaving there
and like [__]
[Laughter]
all right so now we're gonna come to the
moment of truth
so but i don't know i'm frustrated i'm
broke
i don't know what the [__] i'm gonna do
and
uh i started
i forget what the [__] you call this
it's when you go and watch
acting classes and [__] like that you go
like
watch acting classes or what the [__]
and uh i had already taken a beating
on the well the cbs show we are not
shooting
we were still like they were still like
in pre-production
and stuff like that they had given me a
check already
i wasn't a big check it was just a
little check just to hold me until they
shot the pilot
it wasn't big money at the time uh the
money they gave me had to pay the
girlfriend back
i owed her a [__] ton of money and
she took [__] half of it right off
the bat
so one day i was on hollywood boulevard
and i saw a thing for
a free commercial workshop
right but i didn't read the fine print
right
you know none of us do we never read the
fine print
so wednesday seven o'clock i was off but
it was on the other side of hollywood
boulevard
so i go down to the [__] uh thing at
seven o'clock
and these people are dressed kind of
[__] weird you know i'm like wow
like when i say dress weird the acting
people had suits on the people who were
teaching the acting
the one guy had a suit on and there were
other people in the thing i didn't know
if it was an acting school
excuse me i didn't even know what it
really was i'm just looking around
you know i'm an [__] guys it's 1997
i'm trying to learn my way around los
angeles i
[__] go to this thing it's a two-hour
workshop with the half-hour q a or
something
whatever i can live through that i sit
down
i'm taking the [__] class but i'm
noticing
that while i'm taking this class let's
say there's 12 people in there
three hot chicks the rest of us [__]
fetch loves or whatever
that there's more people
watching us in the hallways and [__]
that they were in the class and every
15 minutes somebody else with a creepy
suit on
would come in and [__] like this so
they taught us how to stand on the
marker they taught you
you know what questions to ask the
director they were very helpful
i'm not gonna lie to you this is [__] i
didn't know i didn't even know existed
i didn't come from an acting background
so i didn't really it wasn't like i
moved out there
i watched movies and i took pauses and i
know beats and [__] like that
but i didn't really know the whole in
and out of commercial
auditions me i don't want to sit there
for 20 years
i just want to know the basics of what
we got to do we'll do a couple of them
and then we'll catch on
oh well that's what at least i thought
in my head i
did this [__] commercial class we
finish
we do the q a and then they go by the
way we have a surprise
buffet for you at the thing buffet half
the [__] i did in those things
was based around the food you know like
if
if somebody was having something and
because you're broke
you're a broke [__] comic so anything
anytime somebody gives you a gig
you like free booze free beer yeah free
food yeah yeah
so they said a buffet whatever you know
help yourself and
uh ask about what else we have to offer
here
so i go outside and sure enough they got
like little sandwiches like finger
sandwiches and
you know carrots and whatever [__]
dip and whatever the [__] people eat
i swallowed on a few uh
sandwiches and then they asked you about
joining
the commercial courses and all this
stuff and you know
as you know we yes in the depth you take
the brochure
that's interesting is that what it cost
oh my god
i could do that yeah let me just get a
couple you know you just start making
excuses as a consumer
let me come up with a couple of [__]
things and let me see what i can put
together and i come to the class
and then the guy goes oh this is
beautiful
or you could just suck my dick no he
didn't say that but
it's the same [__] thing you know he
goes or
you could um
take an iq evaluation
and see you'd like to take a look at
what we do here
and right away i'm like scientology an
iq
evaluation yeah it's a free iq test
and we talked to you about the powers of
your mind
and what you should do and all of a
sudden he
will [__] i look down and he gives me
like a [__] pamphlet
and it's l ron hubbard it's [__]
scientology
it was because the scientology building
the big this i think there's so many of
them there's one on
sunset across from where mercy was born
at that kaiser
there's one in los feliz my [__]
the chicken joint that's huge i thought
that was a celebrity center
and then they have little deposits of
them like little they own so much
[__] real estate
can you believe that i got taken in by
[__] scientologists
even your uncle joey's a sucker every
once in a while we all make mistakes
i didn't suck that dick though trust me
they weren't looking for a blow job but
i wasn't lying i would have wanted my we
blow i wasn't looking to suck a dick i
was just looking to learn
a free workshop i wasn't looking to get
over i'm sure that they did a great job
i would have figured out a way
how to get into that program
but i swear to god when this [__] guy
says to me
that he's you know would you like the iq
test or whatever i'm like even that
sounded interesting
and i cute that well i don't even know
what my [__] iq is but
[__] scientology because if you'd
like to take the iq test
and then talk to us about the church and
what we do
here [__] uh
i'm like i i don't know about that you
know
and you know i may tell you something i
still remember the guy's name
his name was mario you know why because
he sent me emails after that
after he like ten years after that
after i got the longest shot i got an
email from and he was like hey man i see
you doing great things
would you like to come back and you know
try our acting schedule and all this
[__] and i was like
what the [__] how does this guy still
have my [__]
i mean my encounter with him was
probably
may of 97
and he probably can't contacted me
in 2006. so i was still on the
scientology [__]
database or some [__] but to make a long
story short
i made two thousand dollars
my first year economy my year and a half
of comedy
i made nine thousand dollars
on my fifth year of comedy
1996 was my fifth year economy
so for five years i did everything
that i could do 20 gigs
five dollar gigs 15 gigs
we got a keg of beer you know i i
i wish i could tell you that you know
there's a lot of stories going around
that club owners paid comics with
cocaine
i i would tell you the truth nobody ever
paid me with coke i think two people
gave me a lot of [__] like that but
nobody
and you did what you did you did what
you did and you
went and then and i did it because i
knew
that i was getting stronger you know in
their mind
they thought they would get no we're
getting over on joe diaz we'll make him
do 30 minutes
you know we don't have to pay him and
all we have to do is pay the headliner
like i told mike i knew the animal i was
dealing with
before i walked in there you might think
you're getting over on me
by not paying me and you know
keeping the money yourself but in the
long run
you're making me do the work and that
means i'm getting more out of this
then you're getting more out of this i'm
getting [__] better every you know
with with comedy once the switch got
turned on
the switch was turned on from the
beginning but with me
i knew one thing that it wasn't about
money that it would be
about money later it wouldn't be about
money now
if i could go without it now
the money would come later i always knew
that in comedy i
always knew that the same way i knew
that whether you're a realtor
whether you're a [__] in a band
whatever the [__] you're doing every
time you in that band
read all great bands biographies
read all their biographies what do you
think they became guns and roses
overnight
did you hear about guns and roads like
they had a hit hitchhike to their first
[__] gig
and they broke down two times along the
way and then they had to get up to the
gig and they didn't know how they were
going to get back that's all part of the
[__] journey
like i've always told people you've
never seen nobody go to an open mic with
a tester
have you nobody pulls up to a [__]
open mic with a [__] bentley
you all go in there [__] you know but
some people have money they're well off
but i'm i'm not saying you go up there
like [__]
johnny chooch you gotta [__] pay your
dues
and every time you go in there it's
gonna be different and yeah they're
going to laugh at you
they're going to [__] goof on you and
say hey we made money off you that's
great i don't give a [__]
i got better because of you i dealt with
40 [__] drunk [__] navy
guys because of you you gave me that
opportunity so if you feel
you you made what you took home an extra
50 bucks
i [__] i'm gonna get that 50 bucks
times [__] interest when i get
[__] paid
so don't think that you're doing
something you know when you're working
for a mason
and he's paying you eight bucks an hour
and he's
making fun of you you're learning how to
[__] stack rock
or you're learning how to bend [__]
pipe or you're learning how to install
[__]
floor joints or you're learning how to
install beams
or how to [__] pour concrete that's
all part of it
you know the comedy store pays 15
[__]
dollars a set in the original room
when you watch the documentary all they
wanted to do is get paid
they didn't say about getting paid a ton
of money it's 15
if you do a spot from monday through
saturday
in the original room you're taking home
a whopping
60 [__] dollars so
you know yesterday when i went to the
himalayan place
the girl asked me something that really
[__] up me all night
she didn't ask me the wrong way and
nothing we were just making small talk
and she asked me if i had a hobby
and i was like no
and then this morning at breakfast i
asked my wife i got a lady yesterday at
the massage place
asked me a disturbing question and if he
goes what was it
and i go did i have a [__] hobby
and i'm like no i don't have a [__]
army you know i used to have a hobby
which was stand-up when i got into
stand-up that was my [__] army
that was my [__] hobby and then i had
the second half then i
after i got into stand-up and i learned
how to [__] rotate that for a little
while
i got into another thing called acting
and once i got into that and started
rocking and rolling
you were watching my episode of marin
you ever watched the first time i was on
my episode of marin
when was the last time i i tooted my
[__] horn
i never really don't watch my first
episode of marin
and the second one and everything i did
after that and even the longest shot
not when i read the sign about tree outs
i had no idea what i was doing
i'm talking about the end how i got
looser at the end i didn't know what i
was doing when i got the longest yard
if you want me to sit here and tell you
i knew i knew what i was doing
i had no [__] idea then over the
after longer shot i learned how to take
a character
figure out who the character is look at
all the scenes he has
and then the cat what the character's
arc is
where my arc is where i had to figure
all that on my own
but that's not what i'm here to talk to
you about what i'm here to talk to you
about is
i took that scientology [__]
commercial class
which i forgot all about and i was kind
of embarrassed to say it
but now we gotta i didn't even mention
this on a church i never mentioned the
story
i think the scientology commercial
[__] class
you know what dog i left that feeling a
little [__]
dirty maybe i don't know i think it was
a dirty move on both of our parts
let's just leave it at that i was a
little dirty on my move
it said a free commercial
seminar commercial acting
seminar it didn't say bring your own
money so i went there
to see what i could get out of it and
obviously
they were there to see what they could
get out of uncle [__] joey
and we both [__] clashed but i
guarantee we both learned something from
out of the experience i learned how to
read for a commercial
so i think after that i probably went in
for
if you want me to lie to you i can in
those days
the commercial world was so [__] busy
in l.a
in 97 i would get a call
every night between 6 and 7. for a
[__] audition
that would be at like 11 to 12 or 11 to
one
and god scouts honor god's honor
i would get another call as i was
walking down that audition
to go do another [__] audition
so five times a week that's ten let's
pretend i didn't have two a day
i think i was averaging seven [__]
commercial reads a week
six seven weeks of that you start
learning different things
it's it's rough on your [__] psyche
you know i'm not gonna tell you that at
that time
i knew how to walk in you know after
three or four times
of people telling you no most people
won't come back
i kept going back to those things and
every time i would go i would learn
something different
i would watch this guy i would see a guy
that had
booked a commercial before that saw on
tv
and i would pay attention to what his
movements were i would
watch a lot i think my number one hobby
is watching
i love watching and i love learning and
i love
gathering information i hate
doing things when i don't
have an understanding of it before i do
it i don't need to know
everything about it i just need to have
an understanding of what it is
when it came to acting you know if you
came to me tomorrow
and said joey you're not going to
believe this
scorsese but
put me in a movie i have one line
in the beginning and i have a line in a
candy store later on
i swear to god that it would take a guy
like me
four hours to get you mentally ready
it and that's if you've been in front of
a camera before
i could get you mentally [__] ready
you know um
but when you've been going through so
much [__] rejection
for so long you get to the point where
you don't know what the [__] you're
doing if it's right
or wrong you start doubting yourself
you know even after all those 42
auditions where i ate [__] guess what
happened
i walked into one i've always told you
[__]
you want to hear no from time to time
the problem with us is we're a work in
progress and we hear no
and we want to [__] fold right away
because you hear no
the more knows you get means you're
closer to a yes
you didn't know that i love when people
tell me no
for you guys that are single or like i
can't find a woman
keep asking keep asking
keep asking if you can't find the
[__] woman it's because you're not
going on enough dates
you're not asking you're not asking
you're not engaging
you're not you know you got if you want
something
you gotta ask for it don't beat around
the [__] bush
ask for it i [__]
wanted to just book a [__] commercial
in the
worst way i was ready to quit i was
[__]
disheartened and one day i got a call
[__] to go to bundy street
last good thing that happened in bundy
was [__] oj killed his wife on
[__] bundy down there
whoever the [__] that was i had to go
down to [__] bundy street
bundy had like the best [__]
commercial place ever they had like
eight rooms every time you walked in
there
there was 800 people the place had this
home dog
so you became friends with the dog with
a big ass german shepherd
he intimidated you at first but after a
while you kind of like the [__] dog
i went in there on a [__] thursday
fourth of july weekend
the stripper had made plans
we were gonna do some [__] we're gonna
go down the beach and all this
i'm like i don't want to [__] i just
got rejected 40 [__] times
you know i'm doing comedy at the comedy
store
what the [__] do i give a [__] about a
commercial
but my hobby
this is what i do i'm trying to [__]
learn i gotta go down there
i walked into that [__] commercial
i don't know what he made me do the
guy's name was kishka
that was a director's name kishka
i [__] went in there i did what he
told me to do
i walked out of there i packed
my little [__] vacation and within an
hour i had a call that kishka wanted to
see me the next day
like [__] this is why you don't plan
[__] when you're a comedian there's no
plans it's day to day
there's no vacations because you're
going to disappoint a lot of [__]
people because
every time you plan something on that
week
is when [__] and they want to give you
something
i go to the [__] callback and he
tells me inside the [__] room
are you available on sunday monday
thursday and wednesday and i'm like
what are you talking about and he goes i
really want you for this commercial
you're my [__] first choice i'm just
letting you know
before you leave that i was ready to
suck his dick
do you understand me i was ready to just
kneel
take his [__] white dick out and suck
that kishka dick
where the [__] he was from i just shook
his hand i go thank you very much
i didn't believe him
i didn't [__] believe this guy why
would i
why the [__] would i but i must have
done something than that
he made me do 20 [__] things
drive shine shoes he made me do a
thousand things like you know not
actual shiny shoes like i was making
believe i was shining shoes
i was making believe i was driving and
talking to a guy
you know all these little [__] things
reaction shots
[__] i get home sudden barton
bernardi calls me
they're like hey man you booked the
[__] national commercial
it's a taco bell commercial uh are you
allergic to dogs or some [__]
and i'm like no i'm not allergic to
[__] dogs why do you ask just
because you'll be shooting with a
[__] dog
whatever i'm like oh my god
i booked a [__] national
[__] commercial who oh my god
well scientology they did something
right they taught me something like that
night
it gets better i get down there
monday i'm all happy
i shoot a national [__] commercial
about to shoot a national
[__] commercial i did some [__]
snooping around
this guy kishko was a big time [__]
commercial director
he had done commercials all the time oh
my god i get down there
and before i can say anything the girl
goes joey how
are you great to see you [__]
uh sign over here and she goes before
you go in your trailer
can you go to mr kiska's trailer he's
waiting for you he needs to talk to you
like okay and i walk over this trailer
i'm whistling you know me dog i'm [__] i
just booked the national [__]
commercial
i'm an ex-felon [__] people saying
i'm too old
people saying i'm too dirty people
saying i'm never i don't have a chance i
just booked a national [__] taco bell
commercial you [__] [__]
i get to the trail i knock on his door
he opens the door
he goes joey do you have a minute sit
down i go yeah girls
i don't know how to tell you this
i do not know how to tell you this we're
shooting
four commercials but somewhere along the
line
they canceled your commercial
they canceled your commercial so can you
do us a favor
we don't we we feel terrible about this
so what we're gonna do is we want you to
come to work
just come all three days we want you to
be the first one here on the [__] lot
and the last one to leave we want to we
want you to get overtime
we got tons of food
we want you to eat until you're sick and
we want you to take [__] food home
with you
i was like fine i'll do all the [__]
above
i went in the [__] room and i
i cried i cried for about three minutes
again uh you know
the world hates me my dad died
when you know i was three my mother died
i didn't start freshman year in
basketball
i had to quit high school i ended up
doing drugs
uh my daughter got taken away from me
why
playing [__] violins for myself all
the [__] i had done
i knew this was a waste of time i knew
nothing was gonna [__] ever
help me get over this [__] thing and
nobody was gonna [__] help me
and after my [__] two or three hour
little
joey diaz cry fest as we all [__] do
i went out and they knocked somebody
knocked in the door
lunch and i was like lunch we had great
you know i'm gonna go eat [__] lunch
and i went to lunch and i started eating
lunch
and uh i was there with another comedian
great great [__] guy
uh you guys wouldn't know him a popular
guy at the time
i forget what his name is to be honest
i'm sorry it's not that i don't want to
mention names i just forget what his
name is he's there so i feel at home
there's another
comedian there that became my friend i
mentioned his name and that part of the
story before his name was
buzz baimundo god rest his soul he was a
comedy store regular
i'd been there since day one mitzi just
a great guy everybody loved him
you know i i remember telling somebody i
was on the set with buzz
and they were like holy [__] you don't
know how lucky you are
ask him everything you can about comedy
and mitzi
and the whole [__] thing and i
[__] you know
whatever whatever violin i was playing
for myself you know
we all feel sorry for ourselves here i
am
[__] eating filet mignon out in the
[__] sun i'm in venice
i had a parking lot down the block from
a [__] great pizza place
everybody wants to be in venice here i
am it's sunny out it's july
you know whatever i got to meet a
director i'm here with two guys
i got i booked i booked listen i booked
the [__] commercial
with talent they just threw out the
lines
something happened and my commercial got
cancelled
that's it i accepted it and i said i'm
gonna sit here for two days like a
gentleman
not be mad at anything and just eat and
just watch and observe and learn and see
what the [__] is going on
so the the [__] second day tuesday i
get there and it's the same thing
hey man great to have you here kishka
comes over gives me a hug hey man keep
your chin up
hang out eat you know me costa's your
casa
do whatever the [__] you need to do
lunch time comes da da da da
lunch joey come to the trailers i walk
over they have a general seating area
and for that day for that something
happened that day
and buzz started talking and we're all
going off and we're all [__] talking
blah blah blah blah blah
and we're having a good time you know
when you get me started sometimes bro
in the words of the immortal joe rogan
if you give me a [__] opening
i'm gonna go in and close that
[__] door i don't have a lot of
good attributes
but when i'm on a roll and you give me a
small window
i will blow that [__] room up the way
i did alex jones
the way i did at the comedy store
fundraiser i just got a [__] way that
if you give me the right fastball like
my man call me the other day some guy on
[__] uh patreon said they should just
call you
dave kingman because when you strike out
you strike out
but when you go for the [__] for the
for the bleachers
jesus christ you're knocking out of the
[__] part i
must have been one of those
conversations where i was on fire
so help me god as i was walking back to
my trailer to sit there for the next
nine hours
kisha goes hey ups come here i go what's
up he's like
oh my god you had me in [__] stitches
today
listen i'm gonna get in this commercial
if it kills me
i don't give a [__] i don't give a [__]
i'm gonna get you in this commercial
if it [__] kills me he goes today
don't sit in the trailer
sit close to me he goes i want you to be
on that [__] set
and i read somewhere that whenever gene
hackman did a movie
gene hackman refused to sit in this
trailer
he always sat and watched because he
always wanted to be on top of the
[__] shooting i took that from gene
ackman
right there in that moment from 1997 on
i never walked away from the set i was
always close to a set
yeah i went to my trailer at times to
take a piss maybe bang one out
[__] smoke a joint whatever but i'm
always
close to the [__] set because i want
to see what was going on
so that day i had to sit close to the
set do you know
that i wouldn't even [__] turn i mean
i was there
and i wasn't the director i'm not into
that [__]
i watched everything that happened and
there was one moment
where he goes joey come here real quick
just sit right there he goes i'm gonna
run the dog through
and i want you to sit right there and he
took the other comedian he goes hey
come here you sit right there and i want
you to
to make believe you're shining joey's
shoes
so the thing that i did in the audition
while i was shining the shoes
they made him do it and he put me there
and he goes just improvise and talk to
him
i don't give a [__] what you say we're
not going to pick it up in the
commercial anyway
because we're going to have music as the
dog is running down the [__] street
so [__] i'm like here it is
we start [__] i'm laying down now
they're shooting three commercials
they're shooting uh an ecstasy
commercial
where the big fat guy from big city
lights
the big football movie what was the
original
big movie with the kid from dawson's
creek
that came out 20 years ago yeah my
brother used to watch
that was the original three taco bell
commercial that we're gonna use
was the fat guy that opens up the
refrigerator
and finds food that was the kid
from that football movie from dawson's
creek
whatever it's called friday night lights
that was it
friday night lights he wasn't there he
was on the set that day
he was shooting one commercial
another uh actor that i had known i
didn't know his name
was shooting a commercial but the
commercial that they had thrown me into
what was the one that buzz bay mundo was
in
was hired to do that particular
[__] commercial so buzz has
shot his scene already whatever he had
to do
and now they were just making the dog
run down the [__] street and run
around and
boom he sh he goes joey get ready
i [__] get in there three or four
takes i
shoot it he goes hey you never know
at least it wasn't a waste i got you on
tape
maybe after we do the commercial in the
commercial airs and it flops
if you contact me i could send you that
reel for your tape
i was so [__] happy i came in
wednesday
i ate i laughed i had a great time i
shook his hand i told him thank you
you know i found out they could have
just sent me home he kept me
put some money in my [__] pocket you
know i don't know what they were paying
me at the time whatever
i was just thankful i forgot all about
that [__] commercial
and that it happened i still remain
friends with the two guys
buzz and the other comic we went back
and forth for a few weeks after that
i get a call one day
and it's buzz bae mundo and he goes
hey man [__] because i just got a letter
saying that they scrapped my commercial
and they only went with a different
thing
and they took me off the whatever the
set was i don't know
he didn't make the commercial the bottom
line was he didn't make the [__]
commercial
all right no big deal i said to him
he goes did you hear anything i go no i
haven't heard nothing
i go i didn't think i was going to get
it anyway i mean
kiss could just put me in there as a
[__] favor you know i'm not gonna get
nothing
holy [__] i hang up the phone with him
i don't know what made me go outside the
girl i was living with the time goes joe
you got mail
she throws me a [__] letter and it's
son bartominari
and that already paid me for the day the
three days work
like when you shoot a commercial you get
paid within the first 30 days
when you shoot tv and film you get
paid within 10 days it was
maybe i got the check from the
commercial
maybe like i shot the commercial july
4th weekend
we shot to like the 6th and on the 5th
and i got
paid for those three days plus overtime
it was a great check it was great money
i didn't get [__] rich but
this was like the beginning of august
and when i opened up the [__]
letter there was a letter in it
and like [__]
eight thousand dollars in checks
nine thousand dollars in assorted checks
when you shoot a commercial they have to
pay you for every avenue
so they had to pay me for a thing called
wild card
or they could put it anywhere throughout
the day two o'clock midnight three in
the morning
then they had to pay you for something
else
and then they had to pay you for prime
time if that commercial is going to add
during prime time
they got to pay you a certain amount
upfront
and then after it airs they'll pay you
every accordingly so the first time it
runs at 8 o'clock you get 200
the second time you get 400 the third
time i mean it's it's insane guys i
i don't know how it breaks down with i
know it's just insane
the four or five check the three checks
or the four checks i had gotten
to pre-pay me for those things
were like nine thousand dollars
and i was just about to start getting
paid on a spots
so god knows what the [__]
amount was i ended up making between us
now 23 years later
i'll tell you what i made from august
1st to december
31st i made 80 000
off this one [__] commercial
because it was the first one taco bell
had done
and it was so successful they couldn't
plan the second one so fast
so the commercial ad ad ad ad
and it even had during the world [__]
series
then taco bell came out with new
commercials like in november and
december
but it was too late the dog was [__]
tired from my run this [__]
had been played 150 [__] times
and what the moral of the [__] story
is
that that's amazing that i stuck with it
and within one [__] year
there was uh a 72 thousand dollar raise
who gets a 72 000
raise in one year don't worry about it
98.99 i went back to being [__]
dead and broke and that money was all
snorted from
but do you understand what i'm saying to
you here guys
tomorrow's story today wednesday the
16th is
we are a work in progress
if you [__] shoot yourself in the
foot
every time nobody says no or if you
consider yourself
failure is if you don't try something
that's what failure is that's what
complete failure is
is you not even [__] trying that's
failure everything we do in this life
is a work in [__] progress when we
did
beauty and the beast it was a work in
progress when we did
the church of what's happening now i
want to work in progress and uncle
joey's joint's going to be a work in
progress
right now right now you might be looking
at this call what the [__] going on
in time we'll have guests and time will
have a different studio
and time this will be something that you
i'm patient and
unfortunate because i've done this 10
times already
i've known that this life that we live
is a work
in [__] progress and if you do it
right
and you wake up every morning with good
intentions in your heart
you'll make progress every [__] day
every [__] day
i make progress you guys have seen it
you don't believe me right now
go on a side by side and look at what i
look like on the church the last two
months
and look at what i look at like now it's
two different [__] people
it's two different looks i didn't get
plastic surgery
i didn't get my eyelid [__] fixed or
nothing like that
i didn't get wrinkles or botox nothing
like that
i work we're a work in [__] progress
you know people work out for three weeks
they don't lose five pounds they jump
out of [__] window
i know that it might take four weeks
just for your body to get adjusted
to this diet and all of a sudden you
lose 20 [__] pounds
if you don't stick with it nothing's
ever gonna [__] happen
we are all works in [__] progress
works in progress every [__] day
if you judge yourself or if you get
frustrated
by your actions because you failed at
something
no take that failure look at it
did you guys watch the ufc the all-night
junior dos santos lost
did you see when they were
you know announcing the [__] results
how he was looking at the floor or he
was looking out into space next time
those fighters are fighting
and they lose look at their faces and
they're looking out into space
because to get a chance it's the most
it's got to be the most humiliating
thing for a human being to go through
when i bomb i got an opportunity i could
just walk off the stage
and walk off out that door and not have
to see anybody
that's the opportunity i get when i eat
a bag of dog [__]
i just walk out the back i don't need to
see you [__]
i go home cry my [__] tear
and i got another show tomorrow night
but when you fight or you do something
like that
the first thing that comes to your mind
all the things that you did wrong
you start thinking looking at the reason
why they're looking at the floor
or they're looking out sometimes they
try to clap to be good sportsmans or
whatever
but the whole time they're thinking
about what they did wrong
to be on the end of the other side of
what they thought was going to happen
every time i go on stage and i bomb i
learn something
every time i do a podcast i [__]
every time but i don't learn it by not
doing it
so do yourself a favor and do me a favor
and do the world the [__] favor
you are work in [__] progress
listen i'm the first guy that shouldn't
you you guys are yelling at me going
you're a hypocrite you're [__] hard
on yourself
you say bad things about yourself i have
to i have to somebody's got to be hard
on you
somebody has to be hard on you you know
my wife is hard on me but not like to
the point that i'm [__] hard on me a
heart on my podcast
or on my stand up on my writing you got
to be hard on yourself
you shouldn't demand nothing but the
best from your [__] self
you owe that to your [__] self for
years i didn't think i i know i went to
prison
i did this my mother died i don't
deserve it i [__] deserve
everything you guys [__] deserve and
you guys deserve everything i [__]
deserve
we all deserve to succeed but it's not
gonna happen
if you're scared to fail and it's not
gonna happen if you don't realize
that you are a work and [__] progress
i am 58 years old you are 22 years old
i got you by 30 [__] years of hard
cold experience and knowledge and
getting beat up every [__] day
that is why i'm here i know what the
[__] i'm talking about
and i'm telling you in 2021
covert all this [__] this is all
gonna change
and you're gonna have your chance all i
want you to do is be prepared
and remember there's nothing wrong with
[__]
failing we've made that like oh well
it's a goof it's a joke you fail you
actually
won because you're gonna come back that
much
[__] stronger and that's it i don't
want to talk about this no more
i want to talk to you about something
that's hot and popular and he's got my
support
i don't know if you guys have been
noticing this for the last month or so
maybe two months sammy the bulgarvano
has been releasing just little excerpts
as a matter of fact i've been watching
sammy
little release tapes that he's just
releasing on little stories
every day he releases a story on the
internet have you noticed that mike
you noticed that have you been watching
those everyday alley boy
he tells the story about you know when
he was at the columbos
when he almost shot he tells you one
story every day well i'm gonna tell you
i'm gonna make you a bold prediction you
guys know i don't [__] [__] around
with you people
the best podcast of 2021
is gonna be the sammy the bull podcast
that premieres tomorrow
december 16th on the 35th anniversary
of him shooting paul castellano well he
didn't shoot paul castellano
he devised it with john gotti i'm not
here
um to
support criminals or whatever i just
know you guys like good stories
this guy's got a story to tell he said
tell it sincerely and he's going to tell
it from the [__] heart
the problem you have even as a podcaster
you know i've had a couple people or i
had
one that claimed to be a gangster's
daughter
uh you know i think ari had
somebody who was pablo escobar's [__]
daughter or wife
people don't want to hear from
second-hand accounts
they really don't they really don't give
a [__] they'll watch
don't listen to what you have to say
people want to listen to the real deal
listen to me samuel bull is the real
deal
yes things happened oh well he's a rat
show
he did this we all did a lot of things
sammy is a crook but if you know
anything about him he's a gentleman
and this podcast is really going to open
up a lot of people's eyes
this guy's got a lot of [__]
knowledge a lot of knowledge
and if you like this sort of stuff he's
going to have fbi people on there
daughters handlers x [__] gangsters
that were there with them
this ain't some guy just talking for
attention this guy's not that type of
guy
when this guy was a full-time gangster
mafia
didn't have a good mod didn't go out at
night
refused to go out at night hated living
like that
hated all that [__] he was true real
secretive quiet cozy nostra
later on things developed with him and
john gotti
i don't know i wasn't there and neither
was you
so let's find out why he read it
tomorrow it premieres on youtube
december 16th i think they shot
castellano on 85
maybe so we got to be talking about 15
and 20.
that's 35 years from the anniversary
[__] it if you murdered somebody 35
years ago
it's on the um it's forgotten by now who
gives a [__]
knock yourselves out have a great week
you bad [__]
thank you for listening remember we just
work so [__] or just work some
project
it works in progress i'm starting
working the projects who the [__] works
in the projects here
what works in progress don't beat
yourself up
give yourself patience have a plan and
you'll get to where you need to go with
and time i love you guys thank you for
watching uncle joey's joint
what the [__] and now for a word
from our sponsors all right i had a good
time with you [__] today
we talked about some crazy [__] i don't
even know what the [__] i talked about
god
only knows but listen before we leave i
gotta talk to you about something
basketball is back football is in full
[__] swing
college football is in full effect the
big ten is back the big 12 is back
the sec is back the acc is back
and next week the nba is back it's like
[__] herpes everybody's back
except you you're not [__] working so
if you sign haven't signed up
for draftkings yet now is the
[__] time
to celebrate the return of basketball
draftking sportsbook is giving you a 75
point
spread on the team of your choice joey
what the [__] are you talking about
that's right you're getting 75 on
opening night
if your team doesn't lose by more than
you will double your [__] money
there's so many games right now
basketball college [__] chinese
ping-pong
you could make some guinness walk the
walk-ins
if you haven't signed up yet now is the
time right now
today we got games tonight you got a
college basketball tonight
you got preseason nba tonight you got
the nfl tomorrow
what the [__] are you waiting on
download the app right now it's safe
secure
and reliable it's your [__] money
deposit at your convenience and withdraw
at your convenience right now today why
are we having this [__] conversation
every [__] week i'm here telling you
they got an online casino
they got prop bets they got everything
you can [__] watch
listen go to draftkings right now why am
i even [__] having this conversation
with you
draftkings sportsbook right now
draftkings.com use code joey
and get a shot of doubling your money on
opening night of basketball right
limited time only that's draftkings
sportsbook right now tonight download
draftking sportsbook app
use promo code joey and when you sign up
i'm going to give you
a 75 point spread on opening night
for a shot to double your money all
right now we got that [__] settled
i gotta talk to you about what the
lawyers make me say you got to be 21 and
all
that's it if you're 18 go [__] yourself
new jersey indiana pennsylvania
colorado tennessee
you're only deposit bonus requires a
25-time play-through
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
slash sportsbook for details now
if you got a gambling problem i don't
want you lurking around here you little
creepy [__]
you gotta throw that otb now you're over
here bothering me
don't come over here get take care of
your problem there's help for you
call 1-800 gambler or if you're in
indiana
call 1-809 with it but if there ain't no
[__] problems
what are we [__] waiting for download
the draftking sportsbook app right now
use code joey and let's make some
[__] christmas money
the joint is also brought to you by i
told you in the beginning of this
you're looking for a gift for somebody
everybody needs to eat right
unless you got [__] freaky vegan
friends then you can send them a dozen
eggs tell them to go [__] themselves
but if not united artists is the gift
for you to send
there's a lot of companies out there
that sell you meet the box
i agree with you but it never looks like
the [__] pictures
by the time you get the meat it's that
mafia meat they send to las vegas
that they dip in chemicals and [__] like
that not with united harvest
it don't taste like the cardboard they
sent them these guys united harvest sent
me a box of meats
forget about it tremendous pork bellies
ribs briskets
chops sausages a lamb and a rib eye
that's [__] tremendous
plus they got a new york new york strip
from the cows that eat potatoes not
[__] corn
these cows eat better than you do on
most days
and you can taste it in the rich flavor
of the meat
lamb chop so tender they fall off the
bone i don't need lamb chops
my wife loves them and she says they
were [__] tremendous
plus the huego beef is tip top [__]
magoo
everything gets processed in oregon by
an expert butcher
and sent overnight so it's premium
fresh and fast united harvest a playing
games
get high quality small batch meets
at surprisingly good price and support
small farms who do it old school
the right way not like these [__]
savages today
you don't even know what the [__] you're
eating your meat and your chicken
plus like i said united harvest makes
the gate a great gift especially at pet
prices
what i'm going to do for you is this
over the holidays go to
unitedharvest.com right now
pressing code joey i'm going to give you
20 off on any order over 50
that's a deal itself right there and
this makes it
the perfect christmas present unless the
guy you know
i'm not i'm a keto vegetarian then then
probably even friends with these people
do yourself a favor
go to unitedharvest.com use promo code
joey
at checkout i'm going to give you 20
off your order when it's over 50
or more stay out of the grocery store
all right
i'm saving you here from colvin i'm
saving you i'm giving you a chance to
get great meat
at a great price value quality
flavor and convenience check out
unitedharvest.com
and be sure to use promo code joey to
save 20
off your order of 50 or more
it's also brought to you with uncle
joey's joint
from my peeps over there at cbd lion
making it happen not like the [__] you
get at some [__] liquor store
or some [__] shoe store or you know
these specialty
i don't know these people you go in
there they got some sales girls telling
you [__]
but they don't really explain to you
what's really going on cbd lion breaks
it down for you
go to cd cbdlion.com educate yourself
go to cbdline.com educate yourself
see what we're talking about see what
terpenes
are understand how they work to solve
your problem whatever it can be
kinesiology tape cbd gummies
tincture chocolate bar however you need
to ingest it we have it
if you want to rub cream on we got a
roll-on for you for your shoulders
whatever
cbd this is as good as it gets
and the proof is in the pudding go to
cbdlion.com right now
and press in joey and get 20 off
delivered right to your [__]
crib who else does that for you
nobody i want to thank cbd lion
i want to thank unitedharvest.com and i
want to thank
draftkings sportsbook for always being
there
and they're always there for you also i
want to thank you guys for watching the
show
i love you have a great weekend and i'll
see you guys
next monday christmas [__] week ready
to get this party started
i love you [__] stay black
that's it nothing but smoke hopefully
the fire alarm will go off i don't
[__] know
you